[Music]
smoke breaks coffee breaks executive
time we all try to find time at work to
escape from the grind doesn't matter
whether you're the president or a school
principal it's wise to take your brain
from a sprint to a stroll what is the
right balance of focused versus free
thinking how do we arrange our minutes
at work to reach optimum productivity in
this week's reporter's notebook we
search for those answers the president's
schedule was leaked this week presumably
by somebody who works for him who
doesn't think the president works
it showed vast blocks of executive time
a period during which the president can
do anything he pleases for the
president's critics the loosefitting day
suggests he's a loafer I asked Dan pink
about this he's the author of when the
scientific secrets of perfect timing
he explained there's nothing wrong with
the executive time what's important is
what we and particularly a president do
with our executive time a president's
job is to lead more than it is to manage
those who get this wrong clog up their
day with meetings and micromanaging
because the public misunderstands this
president's often have to look like
they're working to avoid criticism but
top executives know that free time is
important to think about strategy and
vision a Harvard Business School study
found that top CEOs carve out about a
quarter of their day for this kind of
creative thinking but other thinking is
required to blue sky visions are great
and all but large organizations demand
systematic and focused work that is done
in those tighter scheduled times so we
should ask ourselves and our presidents
are we using the two types of time
wisely is scheduled time crisp and
informative is free time generating
insights reports from inside the
administration suggest structured time
is chaotic and free time sometimes
occupying nearly sixty percent of the
day often coincides with television
inspired tweets dan pink points us
towards President Dwight Eisenhower's
quadrant system that he created to sort
priorities urgent
and important matters require focused
time important but non urgent tasks can
be handled during executive time where
we all fall into the bog of woe is when
we spend executive time on matters that
are urgent but not important or not
urgent and not important that's lost
time or worse it's time where fire
drills are created that ruin everybody
else's day this is a system that can
work for any of us so Mull it over next
time you have some executive time you
know it's so important because we're all
struggling with how to make best use of
our limited time in a limited day and
how to have more time really for what
some might be think of a selfish time
but really is the time that keeps us
mentally sane keeps us creative
thoughtful empathetic yeah yeah if you
want a guide to this Dan Pink's book is
it's great it's really amazing
thank you yeah it was but it was
surprising here all the executive time
that the President had considering with
what is going on in the country on there
and I will say we have covered a lot of
fire drills yes we have we have all
right nicely done John